objectif de la matinée pour ces
policiers accéder à un champ on
travaillerait des clandestins
il faut les traquer surtout les terrains
ça veut dire au feu un groupe d'une
dizaine de cultivateurs arrivent dans le
champ
les policiers se mettent en place pour
leur tendre un piège
[Musique]
tout petit je rêvais d'aider les autres
sauver secourir protéger finalement j'ai
changé de cap je suis journaliste me
voici à Mayotte petite île française de
l'océan Indien à 10 000 km de la
métropole
département français comme les autres
depuis 2011 après avoir été longtemps
territoire d'outre-mer
merci comme patriote submergé par une
immigration clandestine massive venue
des Comores voisines Mayotte fait face à
des défis immenses en matière
d'éducation de santé d'infrastructures
alors des colles en maternité de
commissariats au centre de rétention je
vais prendre le coup de Mayotte
[Musique]
on a
port de Mamoudzou préfecture de Mayotte
il est 8 heures du matin il fait déjà 35
degrés
une grève des barges qui nous amènent de
l'aéroport plus tard ni voilà et j'ai
l'impression que pas tarder à pleuvoir
en fait
je débarque en pleine saison des pluies
et c'est l'été dans l'hémisphère sud
Mayotte se situe dans l'océan Indien
proche de Madagascar et de la Réunion
elle fait partie de l'archipel des
Comores
ancienne colonie française les Comores
sont indépendantes depuis 1975 sauf
Mayotte qui a voulu rester françaises et
qui après un référendum en 2011 et
devenu le centième département français
20 fois plus petite que la Corse Mayotte
compte pourtant presque autant
d'habitants plus de 220 000 dont la
moitié seulement son français
[Musique]
mon voyage commence à la maternité de
l'hôpital de Mamoudzou
[Musique]
dans cette maternité 15 gynécologues et
une cinquantaine de sages-femmes ici le
taux de natalité bat des records alors
qu'en métropole la moyenne est de deux
enfants par femme à Mayotte on dépasse
les 5 enfants bonjour petit français
[Musique]
c'est 1% de la
1% des enfants français
normalement j'ai pas beaucoup
à Mayotte on enregistre en moyenne 20
naissances par jour du coup la maternité
de Mamoudzou est la première de France
et même la première d'Europe un titre
que cet hôpital doit surtout aux femmes
venues des Comores
cette femme surdise qui accouche ici son
comorienne
on n'est pas loin là
ça veut dire que ça va aller vite
en bateau l'un des pays les plus pauvres
de la planète les Comores dont l'île la
plus proche est à 60 km seulement des
côtes de Mayotte ici elles accouchent
dans un hôpital
ultra moderne et au passage grâce au
droit du sol leur enfant devient
français
Charlotte étudiante sage-femme est en
charge de l'accouchement
[Musique]
respirez bien
souffle bien souffler
à la maternité presque toutes les
sages-femmes viennent de métropole or la
plupart des comoriennes ne parlent pas
français
puis des fois on a l'impression qu'elle
nous comprennent et
au final on sait pas si elle nous
comprennent vraiment si
là je lui demanderai au niveau de ces
contractions
la fréquence si elle a mal enfin comment
elle va quoi si comment ça s'est passé
pour le premier voilà et bon je vais
lire le dossier et je vais voir quoi
mais après c'est vrai que
j'essaierai de la fin j'aurais envie de
la rassurer lui dire que tout va bien se
passer et après c'est au niveau de notre
comportement on essaye de
[Musique]
ça en fait c'est ça c'est justement ça
le comportement le visage
tu vas venir vers moi t'allonger comme
ça vers moi d'accord sur le côté gauche
on attend
[Musique]
le travail peut commencer
c'est bien
[Musique]
c'est bon
bravo
super
bon je vais l'emmener un petit peu pour
le sécher tout ça je le ramène après
ce bébé donc né à Mayotte et à 13 ans si
les parents le souhaitent il pourra
devenir définitivement français
bienvenue en France
[Musique]
tu peux venir s'il te plaît
est anormalement silencieux il respire
très mal il a besoin d'oxygène
[Musique]
c'est un petit garçon
tranquille
aussi d'accord
[Musique]
qu'elles sont en demande ou pas c'est la
même chose pour nous c'est des personnes
donc
en tout cas
pour faire naître des enfants dans un
autre pays il faut être courageux
[Musique]
dans quelques jours cette femme et son
enfant rejoindront les bidonvilles de
Mamoudzou ici on les appelle les mangas
il s'est endorite d'une démographie
galopante sous le lien qui est des
autorités car Mayotte était tenteur d'un
autre record national nettement moins
glorieux celui des reconduite à la
frontière aujourd'hui sur l'île une
personne sur deux est en situation
irrégulière
la brigade anti immigration illégale en
action
cette femme est comorienne mais elle
assure avoir un enfant né à Mayotte ce
qui pourrait empêcher son expulsion
on est obligé de le ramener au
commissariat pour refaire une dédication
beaucoup plus donc poussée pour savoir
si vraiment parce que ça nous arrive
d'avoir des personnes en fait qui se
déclarent comme étant à mère d'un enfant
français et derrière en fait ce sont des
papiers qui ont été prêtés à d'autres
personnes donc là ce niveau là on
l'amène on l'invite en fait à nous
suivre au commissariat c'est qu'une
permettra de vérifier éventuellement
faire venir donc les pièces qui
justifiera qu'effectivement elle est
bien dans vos maires dans ton français
pendant ce temps là une autre patrouille
traque d'autres clandestins ce qui n'est
pas facile
Bacar et brigadier de police il y a
beaucoup des
issues pour s'échapper et déjà eux ils
connaissent les endroits parfaitement
ils connaissent parfaitement il faut
rentrer on peut les voir 5 m le temps de
se rapprocher tu arrives
un homme aperçu au fond de la passe
vient de s'enfuir à la barbe des
policiers
tu avais une voyelle
des très loin
avec les gilets
la chaleur on est obligé de les porter
déjà ses villes ne nous connaissent tous
imaginez comme ça
il nous voit ils vont très très vite
ici c'est où il y a des bidons villes
c'est une concentration des personnes
sympathiques où il y a les maisons un
peu le clôture en tôle
on est obligé d'aller vérifier
parce que souvent ils nous disent ils
ont des cartes de séjour là à
l'intérieur mais un vrai dire ils ont
rien du tout c'est une sorte
il cherche une échappatoire ça il nous
dit attendez-moi là je vais récupérer la
carte de séjour on peut attendre toute
l'après-midi il reviendra jamais dans
des maisons il y a toujours une autre
issue en fait vous voyez la porte
d'entrée mais eux ils ont toujours
d'autres endroits pour sortir c'est fait
exprès il faut faire gaffe quand nous
dit je vais chercher les papiers ça veut
dire qu'il reviendra pas
ça c'est clair
donne-moi la main
toujours à des familles qui connaissent
parce que le fait de l'expulser c'est
sûr qu'il cherche à revenir
il revient il a déjà tout ici
depuis combien de temps vous êtes sur
Lille
j'ai 12 ans ici mais pourquoi vous avez
pas essayé de vous régulariser alors
moi j'ai failli d'en face
c'est des pertes des enfants français ou
non français ouais c'est ça tous les
pièces d'identité photocopies comme ça
c'est des feuilles blanches photocopier
coller dessus il faut tous les amener au
commissariat parce que souvent l'enfant
peut être comme là c'est perdu l'enfant
français mais c'est pas forcément que
l'enfant
et de lui ça peut être son cousin et il
scanne tous les documents un qui a un
document toute la famille
madame bonjour la police madame
j'aimerais bien que vous me présenter
vos pièces d'identité s'il vous plaît
pardon votre pièce d'identité s'il vous
plaît madame
vous habitez où ici vous allez le
chercher les documents pour qu'on puisse
vérifier
et pourquoi tu me fais le mien
son enfant en fait il est de père en
journée me rejoinaise à l'âge de 13 ans
il a demandé la nationalité française ce
qui fait là la dame de
[Musique]
on se revenus peut-être trois ans avant
on aurait pu
merci beaucoup
parmi la vingtaine d'arrestations du
jour 14 personnes seront expulsés vers
les communs
mais il en sera arrivé au moins autant
sans compter les naissances
et moins de ce paradoxe Médecin du Monde
qui s'est installé en plein cœur d'un
bidonville
donc bienvenue donc c'est le centre de
soins de médecin du monde ici on
accueille les enfants principalement
pour une consultation de soins de santé
primaire on est dans un quartier
si vous voulez avec des mangas les
difficultés d'accès à l'eau pas toujours
l'électricité pour tout le monde voilà
au dessus là il y a une bande fontaine
donc un système collectif d'accès à
l'eau par exemple il y a pas un accès à
l'eau on va chercher à l'eau exactement
[Musique]
et le système public français on essaye
de faire fonctionner le système public
donc comme il devrait fonctionner
c'était pour tout le monde sans mon
centre discrimination et du coup on
essaie de témoigner surtout des
difficultés en fait un peu plus ça
ces médicaments politiques
[Musique]
qui affiche complet et comme chaque
matin on explique aux nouveaux venus le
rôle du centre
on est là pour vous expliquer des choses
vous soigner vous orienter vous
comprenez
sur lequel est pour nous très utile
quand on est sans papier ça nous évite
de courir parce que des fois on veut
bien se rendre à l'hôpital pour aller
soigner nos enfants mais on n'est pas à
l'abri de se faire embarquer par la
police
au moins ici on n'a pas à faire de long
déplacement risqué
c'est le binôme choc de la consultation
l'une peut pas faire sans l'autre en
fait
[Musique]
pour nous c'est une bonne durée
au programme de Mariame et Brunel 15
patients qui souffrent de pathologies
très variées
[Musique]
l'un d'entre eux attire mon attention
il a été donc
quand est revenu ici une situation
difficile une famille qui est nombreuse
donc le bébé a très rapidement perdu du
poids et les rendez-vous au rééducation
n'ont pas été honorés
et pour ça pour savoir exactement ce que
c'est il faut faire une échographie vous
savez comme comme quand on est enceinte
pour regarder le cœur du bébé
au niveau pathologique on arrive à avoir
des pathologies du tiers-monde ici
ce qui est sur sur Mayotte il y a de la
lèpre mais on n'a pas dermatologue sur
l'île donc c'est difficile de faire le
diagnostic il y a des tuberculose encore
quelques foyers moi je vais pas
forcément voir chez les enfants on voit
surtout c'est les retards en fait de
prise en charge des retards de
consultation et puis et puis quelque
chose par contre qui est très très
criant et qu'on voit dans les pays lit40
c'est cette problème de malnutrition oui
[Musique]
Mayotte terre française a parfois des
allures de pays du tiers-monde en
témoigne son système scolaire notamment
en primaire la moitié de la population
est en moins de 20 ans on manque tout
simplement de place dans les écoles
on arrête juste avant la pluie je crois
j'ai rendez-vous dans une école primaire
l'une des plus anciennes de la région
des écoles de la de la circonscription
parce qu'on fonctionne pratiquement avec
des grosses structures comme ça ou 20
pour la musique là et bien c'est mon
portable
qui rentre 471
la différence
qui a qui c'est une école en rotation
donc rotation à 100%
un groupe travail le matin et notre
groupe travaille l'après-midi
[Rires]
et puis bon elle est pas super moderne
votre école
voilà c'est une école très ancienne très
ancienne on est loin de la semaine de
quatre jours alors il faut s'adapter
puisqu'il y a autant d'enfants mahorés
et donc français que de petits Comoriens
donc nous allons observer un atelier de
langage oral avec des enfants ou
considéré comme des prix noir qui sont
pris en charge
à faire là parce que vous faites pas la
différence
des concernés et l'école est obligatoire
à partir de 6 ans jusqu'à 16 ans bonjour
les enfants
[Musique]
quelque chose de la
semaine
les
amis je brille vendredi ça veut dire
immense on a des difficultés
en 15 minutes
leur permet de s'exprimer sans exception
parce que on doit tous les faire parler
ils ont du mal parce que déjà c'est pas
la langue maternelle
alors on récapitule mon verre
[Musique]
des enfants qui parlent pas forcément
français
moi je dis que vraiment c'est bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez bien travaillé et continuer
toujours à travailler
[Applaudissements]
pour que ces enfants ait à l'école au
même rythme que nos petits
métropolitains il faudrait construire
une classe par jour pendant 10 ans
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y a des croyances à Mayotte vous avez
des papiers
[Rires]
[Musique]
petite ville au sud de Mayotte il est 5
heures du matin nous avons rendez-vous
devant un collège la veille il y a eu
des incidents des élèves sont tombés en
transe dans la cour il se dit que le
collège serait envoûté par des jeans des
esprits de mauvais esprits les croyances
traditionnelles sont restées très vives
nous expliquer un peu parce que nous on
débarque
normalement ça c'est
il y avait des enceintes là-bas il y
avait des villages avants des anciens
village et comme on a cassé on a
construit le collège dessus parce que là
il y avait quoi il y avait un cimetière
il y avait quoi il y avait un village il
y avait un village il y avait des
cimetières
et qu'est-ce qu'il aura arrivé aux
enfants qu'est-ce qu'il faisait
[Musique]
ils savent entre l'école
à 7h il y en a qui commençait à crier
les esprits c'est pas musulman
non-gage mais c'est pris dans nos
ancêtres on a trouvé dans nos ancêtres
que c'est une tradition c'est un mélange
là et donc là qu'est-ce qui va se passer
alors
[Musique]
laisser les enfants que faire et la
rentrée à lieu ce matin à 7h ils seront
là ils seront là pas de souci
tout le monde est d'accord
je comprends très bien
il est 20 de brandir les temps d'art de
la laïcité
95% des habitants sont musulmans et la
République doit faire preuve de
souplesse pourquoi
pour un métropolitain comme moi la Seine
est surréaliste tous les imams du sud de
l'île se sont rassemblés dans la cour du
collège public pour réciter des prières
sans ces éloigner les esprits
[Musique]
et certains de mes collègues
journalistes locaux semblent aussi
étonnés que nous et le jeune journaliste
Morin que tu es lui qui regarde sa
commande
métropolitain parce que j'ai grandi à
métropole et je suis arrivé ici à
quelques années seulement donc je prends
ça avec un petit peu tranquille
en même temps bon voilà je suis pas trop
l'habitude de te voir
de la République
la principale du collège une
réunionnaise doit s'adapter elle aussi
aux particularismes mahorel
c'est quand même étonnant de voir des
prières dans une école de la République
il y a des croyances à Mayotte on est à
Mayotte donc il y a des croyances et
nous respectons les croyances bon là la
demande c'était que ce soit fait avant
que les élèves arrivent pour que
effectivement l'établissement retrouve
son cours normal calme sérénité je n'ai
pas arrêté d'utiliser hier le terme de
surréaliste mais on est dans le
surréalisme
voilà mais bon que faire
et quand les cours débutent le calme
semble revenu
on attend 5 minutes et on vous fait
rentrer d'accord
la rentrée se fait sans encombre les
esprits ont déserté l'école de cinko
[Musique]
à l'autre bout de l'île la traque au
clandestins continue
la brigade anti migration au Père cette
fois en pleine brousse sur la route les
policiers font une première rencontre
bonjour vous avez des papiers sur vous
très bien
ils sont assez tranquilles parce que
sinon que sont en situation régulière et
n'hésite pas à poser leur leur fagot là
et puis sauter directement dans le dans
le ramadan
objectif de la matinée pour ces
policiers accéder à un champ ou
travaillerez des clandestins
il faut les traquer sur tous les
terrains
un terrain un peu atypique pour Denis
et ils gardent les troupeaux les chiens
elles se sont tous des enjouanés qui
n'ont pas de papier
des envoisnés c'est-à-dire des comoriens
qui viennent de l'île d'Anjouan la plus
proche de Mayotte
c'est qu'on est repéré
ça veut dire au feu
[Musique]
un groupe d'une dizaine de cultivateurs
arrivent dans le champ
les policiers se mettent en place pour
leur tendre un piège
[Musique]
oui puce
ils se sont arrêtés
ok on attend
étonné qui courent très vite il faut
trouver des un peu des stratèges parce
que sinon on court toute la matinée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
tu les vois encore
il doit être nombreux en bas qui
chauffent sur lui-même comme ça
et reste en place et il y en a qui
cultive pendant que il fait le il fait
le chou-fleur le Chouf autrement dit le
guetteur et au cas où les policiers
sont équipés
parce que comme ils sont tous des
machettes nécessitent pas s'en servir
donc faut faire quand même attention
pour l'instant
j'ai encore jamais tirer avec donc c'est
tout se passe bien
une demi-heure plus tard l'équipe décide
de se replier les clandestins se sont
évanouis dans la nature ils ont lâcher
leur
baluchon puisse nous ont entendu
alerté par les guetteurs les
sans-papiers ont abandonné toutes leurs
affaires dans leur fuite
ils sont barrés
mais le chemin qui descendait tu
m'étonne c'est tellement lourd
les policiers redescendent vers la
vallée
et dans le premier village qu'il
traverse
bonjour
où est l'acte de naissance des enfants
des enfants
qui sont nés ici j'avais déposé encore
depuis septembre
policiers qu'ils ont des enfants nés ici
s'il ne parviennent pas à le prouver ils
seront expulsés mais quand des parents
sont expulsés dont les enfants ne sont
pas né en France mais au Comores parfois
il les abandonne sur place à Mayotte
dans l'espoir de revenir vite résultat
il y aurait plus d'un millier de mineurs
isolés dans les rues de Mamoudzou
je fais la connaissance de Cala
journaliste dans un hebdomadaire de
Mayotte
elle va me faire rencontrer ses jeunes
[Musique]
isolé c'est que les parents ont été
expulsés on considère qu'en fait il y a
pas un adulte référent on va dire pour
l'enfant ou les parents ils visent quand
les parents sont expulsés ils le disent
jamais qui la plupart ne disent pas
qu'ils ont des gosses et parce que dans
l'espoir qu'il revienne donc ça ne sert
à rien de repartir avec un enfant
sachant que de toute façon ils vont
retenter d'entrer sur le territoire
c'est quand même plus cher et peut-être
plus dangereux aussi de voyager avec un
enfant le souci c'est que le retour
n'est pas si évident que cela
PAF et ils seront reconduits directement
sinon par malchance il faut naufrage et
il meurt quoi donc il y a des gamins ici
qui ont pas vu leurs parents depuis un
certain temps
[Musique]
vu on sait pas trop je me
où sont vos parents ils me disaient ils
sont partis en voyage ils disent pas et
qu'ils ont été expulsés
ne sont pas expulsables du coup ils
vivent dans la rue où ils peuvent et
notamment près de la décharge municipale
nous nous irons donc discrètement il est
interdit d'y filmer
[Rires]
bonjour au démarre bonjour
vous savez où et quand on peut trouver
les enfants isolés dans le coin ici
on peut les voir entre 11h30 on peut les
voir vers midi
le monsieur là il a une plantation là et
les gamins vont saccager ça peut
il aime vraiment pas ça j'ai demandé si
sur ce des gamins sans parents et puis
oui les gamins sans parents c'est des
délinquants qui sont qui viennent
s'engager mes trucs ils sont à midi ils
seront pas réticents à parler ils ont
peur de la police mais
ça c'est ce qu'on va voir 11 rue
poubelles
rue poubelle le nom est évocateur nous
nous rendons à la rencontre de ces
jeunes en contrebas de la décharge
nous tombons sur une femme et ses
enfants une mahoraise très en colère
on voudrait rencontrer des mineurs
isolés qui seraient dans le coin
vous allez voir ces voyous ils vont vous
parler n'importe comment vous manquez de
respect là tout à l'heure ils sont venus
m'insulter mes menacer mais c'est le bon
Dieu qui leur répondra ils sont venus
rayer la voiture de mon mari ce n'est
pas normal
nous tentons quand même d'entrer en
contact avec eux
[Rires]
et la dire retourner d'où vous venez
c'est ça
seconde tentative d'approche
le dialogue est impossible il nous
menace carrément de mort la propriétaire
des lieux est folderrage la décharge
c'est à vous mais ici c'est chez moi pas
chez vous
viens me tuer
ici c'est chez moi
matriarcale mais je commence à
comprendre ce que ça veut dire une
voiture
armée de Pierre les jeunes nous ont
suivis notre véhicule
on a fait les frais faites attention là
ils connaissent la zone Park c'est ça
qui est dangereux c'est que ces gamins
là c'est leur territoire ici
qui habite à côté ils sont courageux
ces gamins semblent perdus pour la
République ils vivent en meute pour se
protéger et attendre un éventuel retour
de leur parents
[Musique]
leur père ou leur mère je les croiserai
peut-être au nord de l'île dans ce décor
de carte postale
si j'ai voulu me rendre la bas c'est
parce que la majorité des migrants
Comoriens débarque ici
j'ai rendez-vous avec trois mahorés
Ibrahim Haïti et Ali ils veulent me
montrer le chemin que les migrants
clandestins empruntent pour arriver ici
au nord de Mayotte
à combien de kilomètres là
pour venir des commandes environ deux
heures à 3 heures de temps selon le
selon le temps selon la météo selon la
météo
et alors les migrants ils s'arrêtent sur
le dos en face voilà tout en étant
inconscient qui sont arrivés à Mayotte
par la complicité de d'un certain nombre
d'habitants des pêcheurs ou bien bah ils
trouvent d'autres moyens de de passage
ils viennent je sais pas comment mais
ils arrivent un peu partout quoi à
Mayotte avec avec tous les risques de
servira et tout ça quoi il est drame
qu'on connaît actuellement il y a des
morts il y a des morts
c'est hélas
presque classique
de l'océan Indien on en parle peut-être
pas assez au niveau national en tout cas
en Europe
voilà il faut trouver une solution à
tout ça quoi parce qu'on peut pas
continuer comme ça au-delà des aspects
économiques qui font que maïs ne peut
pas ne peut pas recevoir tout le monde
parce que c'est un fait aussi il faut il
faut trouver une solution pour régler
ses discussions même si ce sont vos
frères sont nos frères
moi mon père il est grand monogramme
mon grand-père paternel et malgache oui
et mon arrière-granaire et les Massaï
les du Kenya donc vous voyez
non mais ça compte de dire que c'est vos
frères parce que tous les gens ici
disent
bien sûr il y en a trop mais malgré tout
c'est nos frères et nous vivons ensemble
parfois difficilement mais nous vivons
ensemble ce qui nous différencie c'est
que
ils ont gardé entité c'est la carte
d'identité et puis voilà c'est les choix
que nous avons ici pour que Mayotte soit
un département français et eux ils ont
choisi l'indépendance
nous partons à la découverte des îlots
il faut 20 minutes de bateau pour s'y
rendre
l'endroit est superbe il ferait presque
oublié les drames qui se jouent ici
quotidiennement
[Musique]
ces dauphins évoluent dans un écosystème
exceptionnel Mayotte et cerné par une
double barrière de corail un trésor
écologique et un piège redoutable
qui se rejoignent sur cette passe ça
fait des à-coups par froid et on risque
de tomber et à beaucoup de nos prêches
ici notamment les passeurs qui amènent
des immigrés ici
ils font beaucoup d'accidents qui
connaissent pas les
différents courants marins les zones de
risques etc là où il faut passer et
c'est très dangereux très très dangereux
le danger pile en dessous de nous les
coraux sont des lames de rasoir
[Applaudissements]
on fait le parcours de ceux qu'on dépose
ici
on peut dire la vérité
ils viennent pas ici parce qu'ils aiment
particulièrement Mayotte ils viennent
ici parce qu'ils espèrent avoir une vie
meilleure
parce que c'est combien le salaire moyen
en fait
c'est 150
j'ai pas les chiffres en tête
concrètement mais je pense c'est 150 à
300 euros quand vous gagnez 300 euros
comment je pense que c'est un beau
salaire alors qu'un Mayotte le SMIC il
doit être net en gros
voilà la différence
ça ressemble à ça les bateaux des
migrants
dans un bateau
voilà
à quel point
des migrants nous n'en rencontrerons pas
des agriculteurs d'ici en revanche on
voit beaucoup vous envoyez souvent des
immigrés comoriens qui arrivent ici oui
il y en a beaucoup jusqu'à 30 par jour
et alors ils arrivent ici qu'est-ce
qu'ils font
quand ils arrivent ici comme ils n'ont
rien à manger
nos fruits ils se nourrissent en
attendant de pouvoir repartir pour vous
c'est un gros problème
un gros problème pour moi parce que ça
me coûte très cher de venir ici pour
cultiver alors si je ne peux rien
ramener à ma famille à mon retour vous
imaginez est-ce que vous êtes content
d'être français vous
[Musique]
moi oui
[Rires]
merci pour votre
[Musique]
ce qui est incroyable c'est qu'on est
les deux pieds dans la misère du monde
et tout ça
au milieu du paradis terrestre quoi
parce que quelque chose qu'il faut dire
c'est que
c'est un des plus beaux endroits du
monde c'était quoi voilà
depuis ici il vient échouer toute la
misère humaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le lendemain à l'aube nous retrouvons
qu'Allah la journaliste
lors de mon séjour je n'ai pas été
autorisé à tourner avec la gendarmerie
ni avec la police des frontières
on se débrogera sans eux
clandestins qui arrivent de six bon
matin pour essayer de les approcher et
discuter avec eux on va voir on va
tenter le coup
espérant que la chance avec nous je
crois que le péché est de la balade
impossible de savoir combien de bateaux
déversent des clandestins sur les côtes
de Mayotte chaque année ni combien de
100 papiers sont expulsés
l'administration française ne communique
pas ces statistiques ce qui est sûr
c'est que malgré la surveillance
policière des quoi ça arrive
quotidiennement
est-ce que tu connais le tarif de quoi
ça
[Musique]
s'est mis entre 200 et 60 euros
par personne
je pense quoi parce que c'est la
puissance
[Musique]
pour l'instant pas de quoi ça en vue
en revanche au loin une vedette de la
gendarmerie maritime navigue à grande
vitesse
on ne sait pas
[Musique]
soudain nous apercevons une tâche
blanche qui semble remorquer par la
vedette
c'est en quoi ça
les sans-papiers sont amenés directement
au centre de rétention administrative
dans les cinq jours ils seront expulsés
vers les Comores
nous nous rendons au centre de rétention
de Mayotte avec une caméra cachée
les clandestins sont détenus dans ces
bâtiments préfabriqués dans notre âge
les familles des clandestins arrêtaient
il y a quelques heures à peine sont déjà
au pied de la grille
oui ils vont aller où ils partent
aujourd'hui oui ils vont être expulsés
dès aujourd'hui
est-ce qu'on peut les voir
non non c'est pas possible
la sœur et la nièce de cette femme
étaient dans le bateau à raisonner elles
sont juste derrière la grille
[Musique]
allez prenez soin de vous vous nous
manquez allez au revoir à bientôt
inch'Allah
tes
deux sœurs se seront aperçus trois
secondes en trois ans
le temps des au revoir approche mes
dernières heures à Mayotte je les
passerai avec ceux qui m'ont emmené sur
les îlots du Nord arretis Ali et leurs
amis ils m'ont invité à voler le repas
de midi le barbecue Maoré
on mangeait la chèvre
bienvenue fonctionnaire du ministère des
Finances
qui font à manger et c'est les garçons
qui font la vaisselle
c'est qu'elles sont invitées
ça va de soi et des fruits à pain vous
êtes à Fribourg oui
mais comme je le dis Mayotte est une
paire française mais au lieu de
l'origine
que j'étais gaulois
ouais je me suis rendu compte que
c'était un vrai africain quoi et là je
suis tombé dehors mais bon
[Musique]
journée
et nous sommes tous des humains
mon pays vient de colonisation
où est le progrès je vais comme le dise
c'est atroce et préférant
mon séjour à Mayotte touche à sa fin il
est temps pour moi de repartir à la
découverte de nouveaux horizons ou
m'attendent d'autres hommes et d'autres
femmes au destin exceptionnel